dollar. Which I'm I'm flattered that
they all think that it's worth that much
money and I'm flattered that they think
they need to do that. And I'm actually
yani
very flattered by all of that. And of
course
they haven't over They overestimate me
more than even I overestimate myself.
But the fact is this.
Why I don't I forget these guys.
You we are weak because we can't even we
can't even help our poor. We we are weak
because we can't even raise money. Look,
we're talking about
Lebanon. Lebanon is a country with 30 or
40% Christian, okay?
We want to raise money for people that
have been oppressed, whether they are
Muslim or whether they are Christian
actually. Because wallahi a lot of
Christians listen, a lot of Christians I
know you guys are watching this.
And I think to be honest this has been
quite bad. The the interaction between
us is not a representation of how
Muslims and Christians should interact.
So I'm honest with you bro. Because it's
too polemical, yeah?
The fact of the matter is this.
We Muslims and Christians have always
really
coexisted.
Muslims and Christians even the Quran
says that the closest people to you are
the Christians. Can you imagine that? It
says
that you will find the ones who are
closest to you in love. You subhanallah
the word love is used in the verse. You
will find that the closest ones to you,
yeah?
Uh in love are the ones who say we are
Christian. That is a verse in the Quran.
Many Christians listening to this might
not know that.
Yeah? In terms of people with Christian
people, we don't we don't want to always
have these antagonistic things.
Sometimes we need to do we need to work
together. Yeah, there are times you
know. Against Zionism for example.
Against Zionism, but let's just say
something even like raising fund money
for both of
for our people. For Muslim people and
Christian people. Lebanon is one of the
perfect places because the population is
almost evenly divided. So we're raising
money for for Lebanon. The people have
been devastated in Lebanon by the
Iranian strikes in the most holy days in
the Islamic calendar with potentially
the exception of Laylat al-Qadr and
potentially the exception of the last
nights
with a difference of opinion among the
scholars actually and the majority say
it's actually these and these.
And
Let's see how much we're able to raise
today by the end of this life. Mr. Avery
was able to raise $60,000 to take a man
who is untrained in law, which is
Muhammad Hijab, to court in USA.
>> And not only that for a video that's
already online. For a video that's
already online?
And and it's the the narrative that been
made is like
what do you call it? We're hiding it.
The video is online, yeah? So it's not
like we're trying to hide that the
video's online. It's got 400 and
something thousand views. So you can
watch you can very welcome to watch the
video. It's not like we're hiding the
video. We're not giving away our videos.
We're not giving away our videos to
especially not to anti-Muslims
and so on and so forth, bro. So 67,000
whatever dollars raised so you can watch
the video on his channel, which is
already on this channel.
It shows how much money they have to to
waste. Not just that, bro. Why he should
give that money to the Lebanese? Why he
should give that Look, poor people, bro.
Instead of grifting, instead of taking
the money and putting it We want to see
receipts for the money that you're
giving that you you've taken from these
guys. We want to see receipts. I mean,
your Christian people should be saying
to you, we want to see you grifter,
yeah? You're a scavenger and a grifter.
We want to see receipts of who, yeah?
What do you call it? What lawyers are
charging you and how our money is being
spent since it's going into your bank
account, yeah?
And it's the case
>> It's going into your bank account, all
right? So you're trying to make money
from Muhammad Hijab, personal money. No
problem, you can make the money. I'm
happy that these Christians are losing
their money, these anti-Muslim
Christians, cuz not all Christians are
the same, but these particular ones I'm
happy that they're losing it. Let them
lose it. But the point is this, can you
imagine can you just imagine that, yeah?
That people are trying to 100,000 pounds
to take Muhammad Hijab to defend
themselves on Hijab in court in a and
he's his own lawyer in the USA and he
doesn't even have anyone backing him in
from the Muslim community. And I do you
know what? I don't want no one to buy
me. I don't give a damn. I don't care.
Do you know how many court cases I've
had? I paid from my own pocket, bro. I
don't I don't need no Muslims to be
paying me money. How many How many times
have I asked you Muslims for money?
Never. I've always asked for other for
other causes. Yeah?
Every time I've I've done seven court
cases in the last four five years. You
don't know about that. You only know
about the two that I lost.
You only know about two that I lost. I
actually had seven. In fact, eight
including the one in Holland which I did
win and it was a historic victory. But
the point is this, I've had many many
many many court cases. Many of them have
settled. Many of them we won. Many of
them we lost. That's just the game of
it. And I don't give a I've never asked
you people to fund my litigation ever. I
have never had the audacity. I've never
been so shameless to ask my people for
money. I'll go make money from YouTube
on the advertisements or whatever it may
be. I will take that money and I will
use it myself as a sadaqa to
to fund my own struggle against the
enemies of Allah. And I'm glad and I'm
happy and I'm very proud of the fact
that all my enemies are the the biggest
enemies of Allah. The biggest enemies of
Islam. The biggest enemies of the
Muslims. I am glad and I'm proud to
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala that Douglas
Murray is my enemy. That David Wood is
my enemy. That these people are my
enemies. Yeah? I'm glad that these
people hate me enough to try and damage
me uh what do you call it? Douglas
Murray and The Spectator essentially
paying a million pound to try and take
me down. And now these other guys from
another country to have 100,000,
200,000.
And the Muslim community, I'm not asking
you to make me rich.
And I'll tell you what, I'm telling you
this for free I am not rich. You guys
know that I'm not rich. You got By the
way, I'm still a council property
tenant. By the way, I still live in a
council house in the government funded
house. I don't own anything to my name.
Try and find something to my name. I
have nothing. Yeah? Because I've given
it all away. Yeah? I've given every
single thing away either to people,
yeah? Or causes or the dawah itself. I
can assure you that. I've given every
single thing away. I'm not asking you to
do what I did. I'm asking you to do just
1% of that. You've got a link. You
People are dying. Subhan Allah. You
can't even bring it to yourself
to give money to these people.
On these day on this day on these days
on these special days. And these guys
are put 100 million pound 100,000 pound
just to take me out. And instead of
that, let's talk about uh istighathah.
Let's talk about uh Ash'ari Maturidi.
Let's talk about Athari Salafi. Is he Is
he Salafi enough for you? Let's talk
about the gender debate. Let's kill each
other. Let's let let the Muslims fight
and kill each other more more more more
more more. And then these guys are going
to do the same thing to us.
Can you imagine? And we're struggling to
fund our institutions to fund our
mosques to fund our basic thing. We're
going to be finished. Wallahi, do you
know what? The far-right have a point.
That's how far I'm going to go. You
guys, wallahi, the Muslims in the West,
you've let yourselves down. You guys
have let yourselves Look at the Jewish
community. Look at the Jewish community.
Look what they've done.
Look at Do you think if I was in the Jew
I was the same Muhammad Hijab in the
Jewish community, you think I'd be like
this?
You You Are you dumb? Are you dumb to
think that? If I was Muhammad Hijab with
the clout that I have and the influence
that I have, yeah? And I was a Jew in
the in Jewish community, do you know how
they take care of me? Do you know how I
would be taken care of?
Yeah?
Do you think that I would have to be
funding my own litigation? Do you think
that I would have to be doing my own
thing? Do you think that I'd be
bankrupt? Do you think that I wouldn't
have backing?
Do you not think that someone like
Douglas Murray who Netanyahu himself
came out and he said Netanyahu Netanyahu
himself he said we need to take over
TikTok. And we made a video about that.
And he said Douglas Murray and he was
praising Douglas Murray. Do you not
think he's got a hand to play? Do you
not think Elon Musk, by the way, which I
will expose what he said about me, yeah?
And he I'll expose it. One day I'm going
to come out and actually expose it.
Because what he
private communicated to me all these
threats.
And the guy was vouching, yeah? Who's
who Elon Musk himself. And you think
it's a lie? Wallahi, it's not a lie.
You've seen it. Yeah, yeah. Have you
seen it or not? Okay, wallahi it's not a
lie. The And I even
I even have it all documented, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
And then the next week Elon Musk came
out. He didn't mention my name, but he
said, "You know what? Tommy Robinson's
got a What do you call it? A court
case." Didn't he say that? And he said,
"In that court case, I'm going to fund
him." He didn't The court case was
against me.
I'm the one who took him to court. So,
you got Elon Musk, Netanyahu backing my
enemies, and we can't even raise 10,000
pounds sterling
to to save some poor people in Lebanon
who the missiles have rained on them and
killed them in the in the building.
Muslims, YOU ARE A DISGRACE, WALLAHI.
You are a disgrace. We enter the highest
of the deal common
from the entire community. Wallahi, the
issue is with you Muslims. It's the
issue with
you, though. It's your It's your fault.
The far right are right because you know
why? Because you can't even take care of
yourselves. We can't even take care of
our own house. The Muslims, I'm not here
to attack the Christians today. And I'm
not here to attack the atheists. You
know what my attack is upon? The
Muslims, cuz they deserve it the most.
You guys have the Quran. You guys have
the Sunnah. You guys have the Prophet
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam. You
are the failures. You are all the
failures. Wallahi, you have failed. You
are
sailing. You are the ones who are froth.
What have you done for the ummah? What
have you done for anybody? You can't
even raise money for the poorest of the
poor. Why are our people the ones
getting bombed the most? Why are our
people getting killed the most? Why are
our communities getting humiliated the
most? Why us? Because of The reason why
is because Subhanallah, the Quran even
tells us you're going to do what? The
Prophet told us you're going to let us
follow the ones who came before you.
You're going to follow the ones who came
before you. You're going to
follow the ones who came before you.
You're going to follow the ones who came
before you. You're going to follow the
ones who came before you. You're going
to follow the ones who came before you.
You're going to follow the ones who came
before you. You're going to follow the
ones who came before you. You're going
to follow the ones who came before you.
You're going to follow the ones who came
before you. You're going to follow the
ones who came before you. You're going
to follow the ones who came before you.
You're going to follow the ones who came
before you. You're going to follow the
ones who came before you. You're going
to follow the ones who came before you.
You're going to follow the ones who came
before you. You're going to follow the
ones who came before you. You're going
to follow the ones who came before you.
You're going to follow the ones who came
before you. You're going to follow the
ones who came before you. You're going
to follow the ones who came before you.
You're going to follow the ones who came
before you. You're going to follow the
ones who came before
Oh, "Kullu hizbin bima ladayhim
farihun." You're attacking this one,
you're attacking that one. Akhi, we're
dead, we're finished already. We're
done. We're we're finished. We can't
even raise money for our poorest people.
We are You are a disgrace. Wallahi, I
realized the Muslims are the problem. In
fact, I'm going to If I'm going to
continue to make a videos, the only
right thing is to make videos about you.
Wallahi, forget about the Christians.
The Christians have done better job than
you. Look at them. Look some of the
nations, I'm way better than your
nations. You did that, it's true. Some
of that the way they feed the poor is
better than what Look at the Jews,
they've come together better than you.
And that's the one that Allah says about
them, "Tahasabuhum jamia'an waqulubuhum
shatta dhalika bi'annahum qawmun la
ya'qilun."
That you think that they're together and
they are divided. They're The Jews are
divided. See, subhanallah, do you know
they've got Orthodox Jews, they've got
Reform Jews, and but when it comes to
Zionism, they all come together. Look at
the surveys. They come together, they
fund themselves, akhi. They can When it
comes to Zionism, a lot of Zionists come
together.
They've done so much of a better job.
There's 10 million Jews in the world.
Let's be honest, there's 10 million
Muslims in Cairo itself, alone. THERE'S
20 MILLION. ACTUALLY, THERE'S 20
MILLION. THERE'S DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF
Muslims in Cairo as a city than there is
Jews in the entire world. And look at us
and look at them.
Let's be honest and let's be real. Look
how united we are and look at how uh
disunited and disgusted. Wallahi, let's
be honest for a second. We've had enough
of just like mujamalah and lies and
trying to make you Muslims feel good and
being apologetic. I'm I'm an apologist
for the Muslim for the Islam. I don't
mind that I'm talking about Islam and
the prophet and like But I don't need to
be an apologist for the Muslims. In
fact, we don't need apologists for
Muslims. You know what we need? We need
people to tell you Muslims that you are
wrong. That you guys are weak. That you
guys have don't back it. You're jealous
of your fellow man. You don't want to
see no one get good. You're you're When
another guy gets any way good, you
destroy him. You put him down on the
floor.
Any guy Who do we have in our
conservative community except that we've
trampled him? We've trampled and
humiliated him so that he doesn't do any
good. So, we can't have any great guys
that are conservative and and somewhat
mainstream or whatever it may be. We
can't have it because if we have it,
then you're going to be upset about it
and you're going to be jealous. And we
got to cater for your jealousy. Control
your jealousy. Control your jealousy and
know that the cause is greater than your
damn jealousy. You're jealous. A lot of
the reason why a lot of people we're not
getting what we need or we don't have
the power that we have is because of
your jealousy. That's the problem. You
need to Muslim, control your jealousy.
Enough is enough. Do you not see that
this is a bigger issue at hand? Do you
not see that we have bigger issues at
hand? CONTROL YOUR JEALOUSY, MY FRIEND.
Control your jealousy. Enough is enough.
Do you want me to attack what?
Christians all the time? You're dumb.
You're stupid. You're the one who could
This is the debate. The debate is about
the infinite regress of the thing. The
debate is about the causes of infinite
regress of causes. Not about how many
religions there are IN THE WORLD. THAT'S
IT.
>> you the point. I just give you the
point. You were still talking. How are
you going to move on?
Okay.
Let's say there is a god There is like
sa- sounds of religions.
What makes Different topic.
You're changing the You're changing the
topic. What do you mean different topic?
I'm trying to move on.
You're changing the topic into a
thousands and thousands of pieces. You
need to You already agree You already
agreed with me. Necessary to
say that You already agreed with me. If
you put If you put someone with no money
and another guy with no money and a
third guy with no I just said I agree
with you like 10 times. What am I
supposed to do?
>> the solution? How do you get money?
The solution is you have to tackle the
shape
Yes, there is a god.
Yeah, yeah, there is a god.
proportional causality, right? This is
actually a principle in
>> [laughter]
>> If you have no money, you cannot give
the money.
If if you can't have no money, you
cannot give the money. If you have no
independence, you cannot give the
independence. If you have no
sovereignty, you cannot give the
sovereignty. If you have no
self-sufficiency, you cannot give the If
you have no ghina and samadiya, you
cannot give the ghina and samadiya.
I just said like
I said like 20 times. I'm sure I agree
with what you're saying. We need to move
on and you're still talking about it.
Can you hear me?
You need You agree You need the
necessary thing. You need the samad,
right? Yeah, I agree. I I JUST
YOU KNOW, I I JUST
>> [laughter]
>> OH, NO, NO, NO. KEEP IT ON. WHAT ARE YOU
DOING?
I just
I said the samad that he One or
multiple?
I want to know
I want to hear leak. I want to know the
leak.
I want to know the leak THAT HE
[laughter] IS
I HAVE A QUESTION.
I said that I I have questions. So, can
I just ask the questions like
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, why are you trying to just convert
me? I I have questions.
Oh my god, man.
What am I doing to myself?
Can we just get to the point where I'm
trying to get? I The whole point that
I'm trying to get I I have questions and
if you answer those questions, I would
be fulfilled.
I am just trying to get to my point
here.
Why does that bother you so much what I
say? It doesn't matter.
I I I will say you right. What I'm
saying right now
Yes, yes, I was wrong. Yeah.
Sure. I was wrong.
>> Okay, good. Good. Good.
So, now we are going to come to the very
simple point if there's one God or
multiple gods. What's your answer,
Guljinder?
No, his name is Guljinder, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> Instead of worshipping the white man, we
want him to worship the Indian man.
Sure, let's say one God.
Is that now we go to Risala, okay?
>> Okay. We go to the Risala. Can I just
ask my questions, dude, instead?
>> [laughter]
>> Oh my God, man. Can I just ask my
question?
Of course you can ask your questions.
But I you know, this is literally what
I'm trying to do. I'm trying to make it
fast forward. You guys are just like I
don't know what you're Definitely, this
is the way forward. I I promise you. I
promise you. You're a good you're I I
have to admit you have some you have
some
humility and I have to admit that you
are fair. You are fair. And you know, at
the something I like about you, man. I
think that you can easily become one of
the great figures in the Egypt and in
the world. You can either be a nobody or
you can be one of the great ones. And I
believe that you are going to choose
today to be one of the great ones
because well, I sometimes you need to go
through this kind of journey where you
become Yeah. whatever you become and
sometimes you know, Allah guides people
in mysterious ways.
>> Yes. Yes.
So, I'm saying to you, akhi,
uh let's get to since you believe in one
someone. You believe in one independent
and we accepted that we know that you
can't bring something from nothing. You
cannot bring
Rina from Fakra. You cannot bring
dependence from independence from
dependence. You cannot bring money from
no money.
You cannot bring uh
uh light from darkness, whatever it may
be, right? We admitted all of this. Now,
the point is to you
is what is it about Islam?
Okay, when you look at the Prophet
Muhammad you you've you've heard about
his life. You've heard about the you've
read the Quran. You're Arab, you can
speak Arabic, you can You've heard the
Arabic of the Quran. You've heard the
pristine Arabic language of the Quran.
You've heard
that the Quran, subhanallah, every
single essentially every single ayah
rhymes with the next ayah until the end
of the Quran.
And if that but it has inside of it some
of the clearest and the strongest Arabic
that any Arab like you should be able to
completely understand. I'm sure in Egypt
they have a good syllabus of al-lughah
al-arabiyyah al-fushah. You understand
exactly that this is the This language
is above and beyond what the shu'ara' of
the Arab that they can produce. You
understand clearly that the Arabs of the
time of the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alayhi wasallam that they understood
that the best and the highest form of
Arabic was this Quran. You understand
that when Allah says fa'tu bi suratin
min mithlihi wa ad'u shuhada'akum min
duni Allahi in kuntum sadiqeen that when
he challenges the people to produce a
chapter like it that no one has been
able to meet that challenge. No one in
Quraysh, no one in the medieval period,
no one now, and nobody has been able to
produce a chapter that has granted so
many people to be following it. Nobody
in history has had anything like the
Quran produced just from a linguistic
perspective. So, I want to know, since
you know that already you you're a a
bright man and you've learned Arabic and
you've you've heard the Quran in the
Arabic and you've heard the naghmah and
you've heard the
rhyme of the Quran.
How
how can you
uh deny it is a miracle, a linguistic
I'm going to go for this one now with
you. A linguistic miracle.
Uh it is a mu'jiza. No one can come near
it like this. How could you deny it?
>> Uh okay. Can I talk? Like you I'm sorry.
Okay.
So, uh first of all, I only believe in
empirical evidence that I can test. If
there is evidence that I cannot test, I
don't care about it. Hinduism, they
believe there are a lot of miracles. I
cannot test it. Therefore, I don't
believe in it.
Uh you can apply this to everything. The
only evidence that I absolutely care
about is uh
empirical evidence that I can test right
now. So, you have the Quran. So, you
have the Quran. Quran is materialistic
evidence that I can use to either
falsify it or
uh
believe that it's 100% true.
It is a
You know but you know for a fact that
the Quran mentions in chapter 4 verse
82.
But if it was from other than God, they
would have found in it many
contradictions. Even what Karl Popper,
who
who popularized in 1994, he died. He's a
philosopher actually and he wasn't an
atheist, interestingly enough. He's he
called it um falsification. You know
what?
Uh it has to be Okay, so for something
to be scientific, it has to uh be
capable of it. It has to be susceptible
to falsification, all right? So, if
that's the case, if it's if something's
to be
a scientific Like you said, it's got to
be falsifiable. The Quran is also giving
you a falsification test. It's saying
that in order for the Quran to be proven
wrong,
they you would have to find a
contradiction in it if you want to prove
it wrong. Now, it's not saying
that this is the sufficient condition
for proving the Quran, but it's saying
that it's a necessary condition for
proving the Quran. So, if the Quran was
other than God, you would have found in
it many contradictions. Um do you find
any contradictions in the Quran? Um yes,
you have the
>> Give me an example of it. You you're an
Arabic speaker, so I'm interested in
what you're going to say. Um that the
earth is created before the sun and the
moon. So, let me let me come with that.
Let me come with that, my friend Ahmed.
You know Allah says in the Quran in
chapter
Baqarah, Surat Baqarah, chapter 2 of the
Quran, it says,
That is what I was talking about, right?
No.
>> So, it
Hm? No, no.
>> Yeah? Uh no, no. Other one.
In Surat Fussilat, yeah. So,
uh I think we love you
with you
What do you call them?
Yeah, that one, right? And then uh so
so much
that one, yeah? Yes, it is.
So this is there's a difference of
opinion among the scholars as to
classically how what was created first.
There wasn't back then. No, there wasn't
back then.
No, let me Uh no, no. If you look at all
the interpretations of
the
Tabari, every person
Islamic scholar
Time let me tell you
>> Can you let me hear?
Can you let me No, I know what you're
saying, but you're wrong. Let me Well,
you're wrong. Let me tell you why you're
wrong. You read Qurtubi and you read Ibn
Kathir. What you'll find is that what
Qurtubi mentions is that Abu Qatada,
sorry,
Qatada Qatada Abu Qatada is some some
figure here. But Qatada was a Tabi'i
who was doing tafsir of Surat Naziat,
chapter 79, verse number 30. He says
He says
and then he says
Qatada took the view that Allah created
the heaven before
before the earth. And Ibn Abbas took the
view of the opposite, that the earth was
created before the heaven. Okay? That's
what is mentioned in Ibn Kathir. So
there is a khilaf. And in fact, Qurtubi
takes the view that
>> No, I'm not talking about heaven and
earth. I'm talking about earth and the
sun and the stars. I'm not talking about
heaven. No, no, no, the sun and the
stars is not a discussion. It's not the
discussion that was made. That was a
discussion between the
tafsir. No, yeah. Yeah, there is no
discussion. There is Ibn Abbas
But hold on for a second cuz I've read
this quite well, yeah. So just let me
say this.
The Qur'an Qur'an doesn't have a
discussion about what was created first
or doesn't even indicate anything about
what was created first, the earth or the
sun. There's no verse in the Qur'an that
indicates anything like that. In the
verse in Surat Fussilat, chapter 41,
doesn't even mention or the creation of
the sun after the earth or anything like
that. It creates
>> Yeah, what about what about the stars?
Uh masabih masabih is another
translation for the stars. 90% of the
stars in our universe have been created
I know
>> this is what they say. It's
he says
in the summer of the summer of the
summer wet. No, not this. I'm talking
about the law.
Which which was he talking about? I'm
talking about for solid after he created
the earth
like after some stages he said what
muscle of the beak muscle of the beak.
No, read the verse that you're talking
about. Okay, one second. I'm looking it
up. You it's in the first or second page
of sort of a text from the law. I'm
looking it up.
And to the core of the law of the law of
the law of the few men to some of the
law of the law of the law.
This one this are you talking about this
verse here?
Uh one second. I'm looking it up.
Uh
Mhm?
Some of the law of the law of the law of
the law of the law of the law of the
Are you are you talking about that?
So, yeah, yeah, I'm look Okay, I'm
Uh
Mhm? Uh
Hey, hey, some of the law of the law of
the law of the law of the law of the law
of the law of the law of the law of the
law of the law of the law of the law of
the law of the law of
So,
so on the summer summer of the summer of
the summer of the summer Oh, yeah, yeah,
so on the summer summer of the your
reference in the right Mhm, mhm, mhm.
You don't you What they in the summer
what they in the summer of the muscle of
the beak That's that's that's not your
chapter. It's a new paragraph. But even
the the three things that I mentioned is
your man and then the what happened in
the what do you call it? Allah created
the thing in four of our fear of our day
and uh so on and so forth.
And by the way, there's three so on and
so on and so on. Anyway, no problem. And
then afterwards so on and so on and so
on and so on and so on and so on.
It does swear is this different to a
whole clock I don't think. So, Allah
says so on and so on and so on and so on
and so on and so on and
He he turned to the heaven when it was
the car.
So, when he when it was already created
then because a lot of them
Dude,
can you can you hear my mic good because
I think you can hear me
I am not talking about heaven I'm
talking about what's inside the heaven
like the sky I'm talking about
yeah it says about the stars
must I'll be
that's the next verse right so it said
what does it say?
Again that's the next verse right?
No
but that is not saying that that this is
just saying it's giving details about
what is the case with the dunya
it's saying [clears throat] that dunya
has
it's not saying that
it says God created
after he created after he created
this is a declarative statement it's not
talking about after it's not talking
about this happened after and by the way
even
cannot be there's some scholars of
that say can be
anyway
sure
but what is the majority view if if we
can just talk about like maybe
views majority minority it doesn't
matter so long as there is a view
because here's the fact with the with
the with the
the
verses which are
which have some ambiguity if there's a
view
of classical scholars before the
scientific age that believe that the
earth was created after the heaven okay
and as I've mentioned believes in that
and believe in that that I mentioned
in his as well so long as that that view
exists and that there's another view yes
that the earth was created before the
heaven which is an unscientific view I
will give you that Plus, this one's
there's a scientific
tafsir and there's an unscientific
tafsir. Is the Muslim because this is
not a mess Allah of Kuf and Iman is is
completely within his right to accept
the minority even or let's say the other
view just like for example the two views
on Sat
some of the scholars of the past
believed that what they called to
believe believed that
Allah was Sat
and Ibn Taymiyyah and
what do you call it others they said no
there's Ijma that I'm talking here
the point I'm trying to make is all all
like 99% of Islamic scholars interpreted
No no no no no no no
Let me explain it to you from another
perspective.
You seem to have a serious problem with
just trying to
shoehorn your view One second. I'm
giving you a very logical answer here.
As long as the Let let's look at the
tafsir of Al Qurtubi to
Look look look you said Ibn Kathir
right? No no You said Ibn Kathir right?
I said Ibn Kathir Qurtubi Okay hold on
go to Ibn Kathir go to tafsir of
In fact you can go and ask a chat GPT.
You write Mas'alat
you write Mas'alat Hal Ardh Khuliqat
Qabl As Sama As Sama Khuliqat Qabl Ardh
yeah? Did the earth was created before
the heaven according to tafsir or the
opposite? You will say you will see
Ikhtalaf Ulama fi dhalik. You will see
this Ikhtalaf. You cannot lie about
that. It's something anybody online that
what do you call it can see right now.
Ikhtalaf Ulama fi dhalik. What do you
call it some Tabi'in Qatada was a Tabi'i
he's from the Salaf. He believed that
the earth was created after
So long as the view is there خلاص
No no no he's
he was insincere by infinity. He was
wrong about the majority of atheists.
No no no now what he's doing is
he's got two different views in front of
him and he's still being obtuse and
going back to have different views and
He says that this tafsir says that
listen views and different views and
different views and different views and
different views
There are two views in Islam. One fits
with science, one doesn't fit with
science. What's your next question?
Yeah, so you have to get some that
there's no tafsir
Every every contradiction I bring up you
just say, "Oh, there is like La because
no, no, no. Aki, Ahmed, I'm I'm trying
to be I'm because look, you're a
countryman and you're Egyptian guy and I
like you and I like your personality,
but I'm trying to give you all the
benefit of the doubt. And also it's
beneficial for us because you're an
Arabic speaker. So you can bring the
best, you know, you can bring the best
shubuhat, whatever. So you've mentioned
this thing about the earth being
created, the sun being created before
the heaven and I've answered it. I said
okay, let's And you can't deny that
there's
and that goes back to the salaf, okay?
And that's it. As simple as that. You
can go for this. You can go for this. It
goes back to this. As simple as that.
Let's okay, okay. I I agree, sure. Let's
get to
You answer this. That's why, you know,
actually he's got a good, you know, he's
got a good vibe on him. Next one, Aki
give me the next one, please. Yeah, I
will give you the next one. So I I like
how this is going.
I like how I like how this is going. I
answer the question.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no.
When some of the
when someone asks a prophet about the
sun, where does it go when it's when it
sets?
Yeah, yeah. He literally told him that
when it sets,
it
goes to under the throne of God and So
the hadith that you told me about is the
hadith of Abu Dharr al-Ghifari, right?
And this mentions Sahih al-Bukhari. It
says "Ayna taghrub al-shams?" Right?
Where does the sun set? And he says
"What do you call it?"
That it goes under the the throne, okay?
And then
What do you call it? It goes under the
throne of Allah, yeah?
Is that what you're talking about? Yes,
yes. طيب
Okay, what's the problem with that one?
Uh so, clearly uh God didn't tell
Muhammad that the sun doesn't go
anywhere, that the earth literally
revolve revolves around its axis. So,
the phenomena of sunrise and sunset
No, no, no, no. Hold on. Let me Let me
answer that. Yeah. In the Islamic
cosmology, where's the Arsh?
Uh above, like Above the seven heavens,
right? Yes. Sure. So, are we under the
Arsh now?
According to the Islamic cosmology?
Yes.
Yes. Is the sun under the Arsh now?
Sure.
Yes. Is the earth under this Arsh now?
Yes or no? Yes.
Then, if it goes if if Abu Dharr
al-Ghafari is asking the Prophet Alaihi
Wasallam, "Where does the sun go?" and
he says, "Under the Arsh." It hasn't
moved place, has it?
It's still under the Arsh.
He
No, no, no, no. It's not about I
shouldn't have said that. You didn't
hold You you you think it said Wait,
hold on. You know what the
misinterpretation is? You thought it
said under the earth.
I didn't say under the I didn't say
under the I didn't say under the I did
not say this. I did not say this. I did
not say this.
It's not something. You thought You
thought it said under the earth.
>> I didn't say this. You just said
something I did not say. I said it was
always under the It was under the Arsh.
It was It was always under the Arsh. It
was the problem. It's not going
anywhere, is it?
So, why didn't he just say it didn't go
anywhere? He just said, "Oh, it goes
under the Arsh." It's more poetic. It is
more a spiritual. It is more poetic.
But, the Quran doesn't say Well, hold
on. Uh Here's the question. I want to
ask you a question, uh whatever your
name is. Ahmed. Uh the question is this.
Look at the Quran, the whole Quran, from
beginning to end. It's very interesting
you bring this up. Okay?
Because what Is there any verse in the
Quran that says the sun goes around the
earth? Is there any verse that says
that?
Think about that. Think about my
question. Is there any verse
I promise you and I am willing to wager
there is no verse in the Quran that says
that the sun goes around the earth.
Zero.
Look at
until the end, right? Sure, sure, yeah.
>> So what does it say? It says the sun
when it
it says the sun does this and the moon
follows it and this and that. Doesn't
say the sun could have easily said what
Shamsul to do how long
it doesn't say anything like that. So
the Quran doesn't actually specify where
the sun goes in terms of respective to
the earth, does it? The only thing that
wait, the only thing the Quran actually
does mention
is in this is mentioned chapter 36
number verse number 40 which is sort of
the Yasin that Allah he says
a Shamsul to do most of the Quran in
yeah.
Yeah, do you really
Yes, yes. So it the sun cannot overtake
ask me a question I'm trying to answer.
The sun cannot overtake the moon and the
moon cannot overtake the the sun and
they're all flowing in an orbit of their
own motion and when Abbas we're going
back to the was asked what is it?
He said that it's like and he said like
a spinning wheel.
Then the sun is going around itself and
by the way
this something I'm sure you didn't know
but I'm going to tell you anyway. You
know there is a which is attributed to
Masoud.
Yeah, which says a Shamsul to do a lot
most of the Quran do you know that?
Very interesting phraseology. He was
doing
of chapter 36 verse 40 is it
and he says that Shamsul to do
which means that the sun is running and
it has no place of setting.
Yeah. Aha.
Sure, sure.
>> When you take my
Can I Can I talk? You just made your
point. So, this is all just You're just
talking. You're not saying anything.
You're not doing anything. It's a thing
is somebody asked asked the prophet,
"Where does the sun go?" He said, "Oh,
it goes He could have just said that the
sun doesn't go anywhere. That the earth
It does as he's saying it's going under
the throne, right? So, it's under the
throne in Islamic cosmology is not the
same as under the earth. Right?
So, what's the problem with that?
>> say under the earth. Where did you get
this from? I did not What's the problem?
What's the problem with the Hadith? If
there's no under
>> is that it doesn't even go anywhere. It
is just stationary.
>> somewhere. It's the prophet even in that
Hadith he says he recited "Ash-Shams
tajri li mustaqarrin laha" which is in
chapter 36 verse 40 in Surat Yasin. So,
he actually in that Hadith mentioned
that "Ash-Shams tajri li mustaqarrin
laha" which means that it's running the
the sun keeps running. What Where do you
think the sun is just stationary? That's
wrong scientifically. No, it is not
stationary. It It revolves around the
Milky Way.
So, The sun is running in the in the
solar system. The solar system is moving
by the way.
The whole solar system is moving
like that, yeah?
The whole solar system is moving.
>> Yes. Yes, the sun is moving around the
sun. It's moving around itself. So, how
you say the sun is not moving? You're
wrong actually. The Quran is right, you
are wrong. And by then you you all of
all of this reading of the white man is
You still didn't respond to my fact that
somebody
Deepak. Deepak. Deepak. I've seen in the
last half an hour we've given you more
than enough information.
All I've seen All I've seen
All I've seen from you is insincerity
and you haven't actually thanked
>> he's He believes in somebody. He
believes in one God. Now, he's almost
done. He hasn't thanked the free
education that he received in the school
that he received
He believes the sun is stationary. He
believes the sun is stationary. I did
not believe this. I know the sun is
orbiting in the Milky Way.
It's not stationary. It's moving. It's
the sun is moving. Akhi, the sun is
running and it's turning at the same
time. D- Deepak, we have And the Quran
says that and it's true. Can I ask more
questions?
D- Deepak
Can I Can I ask
Please. Give him one more question.
Akhi, he's eating kosher food.
One more. I'll ask one more question.
Yes. One G. So, there is another Hadith
talking about the resemblance of the
child like uh
>> Yes.
Sure. Okay. No, no, no, it's fine. I I
know these ones. Go ahead. Talk about
It's not you know, he's insincere. No,
no, go ahead. What do you mean I'm
insincere? Because Because any any Wait,
wait, wait. Anybody using 20% of their
cranium would realize by now you're an
insincere creature. Instead of thanking
First, you come up with infinity, you
were wrong. Then you were talking about
majority of philosophers. You jump from
one topic to another when you get
refuted. It's like whack-a-mole. You
whack it here, you whack it there, you
whack it there. Go and give us your next
one. Yallah, khalas. Last one. Come on.
Let's Go on, Deepak. Go on. You get the
strongest one better you have, better.
Actually, this one is going to resolve
all your issues and then you're going to
come back to Islam. You're going to read
the Quran. Go ahead.
>> I have like I have like 20 other more,
but let's say
>> [laughter]
>> You get the strongest one, the one that
causes you the most doubts. The biggest
one, the strongest one.
>> doubt is he wanted The biggest doubt is
he wanted to BE CREATED CREATED
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
SO,
HIS BIGGEST DOUBT IS HE WANTED TO BE
He wanted to be born as a white man.
And he's saying
No, that's the issue. That's the
He worships white
He worships white people.
Okay, so
Uh Uh is the Hadith talking about child
resemblance? Sure. Can you Do you know
it? Of course you know it.
>> Yes, I know very well. So
>> What about the Hadith of this one? This
is our field.
This is our field. What are you talking
about? Which one comes first? Which the
subq?
Hm? So first of all, the discharge of a
woman has nothing to do with conception.
You
>> No, no, is that the Hadith you were
referring to first, right? Yes, yes. Is
that the resemblance of the child?
Yeah, so there's there's multiple ways
of the Hadith. Are you aware of the
multiple ways of it?
Yes.
Are you Are you aware of the multiple
ways of the same Hadith? Wala la.
Because there's two or three different
ways of the same Hadith.
And they all lead to the same I I am
sure La la. So it's not the same cuz
there's slightly different words and
I'll tell you why it's important.
>> Yeah, yeah. One is talking Are you
talking about the like the determination
of sex and yet the other one is the
the resemblance
>> same exact Hadith.
But one of them uses the word subq and
one of them
uses the word hala.
So the you know how in the Quran is
mentioned
walada ma'ahum ilaha
It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. At
the end of the day
>> just trying to do ta'sil of the mas'ala.
We're trying to bring it from the core.
Because you're you're bringing Hadith,
so I'm saying this Okay, you brought
Hadith, I'm saying there's many
different versions of this Hadith.
That's the first thing we have to
understand.
Because there's different shuruhat of
the Hadith. Now, here's the point. What
does this Hadith say? Does this Hadith
say
uh which one of them
basically ejaculate first? It doesn't
say that.
It doesn't say that. Hadith doesn't say
which the man or the woman which one of
them ejaculates first the child is going
to resemble them. It doesn't say that.
Hadith doesn't say that. It doesn't say
that. You can look it up.
>> say that. It does not No one
No the word is What do you call it?
Ejaculation is not there.
It's the word is there. Is there.
The word ejaculation is not there. Uh
discharge?
La la la la la la This is where this is
This is where you got it wrong. Because
what it says is that the one which which
of the two, yeah?
First of all, let's go to the Quran
because the Quran gives you the first
indication.
This is requires an explanation.
Allah says in Surah Insan, which is
chapter 76 of the Quran,
Okay? So here you have the first
indication. The it says in the
min
and never tell
for general Samir Basira. We have
created the human being
from a mixed fluid, okay? Which means
what? There is
There is a contribution a genetic
contribution from man and woman. Clearly
the Quran is indicating that the nutfa
is not just the man's genetic material
being embedded into the woman. Clearly
the Quran is saying that is
that it is a
biology. It is a biological and genetic
contribution from both the male and
female. Correct? Of course. There's no
difference of opinion there. Right, we
move to this Hadith. The Hadith has
different ways. The Hadith says in one
way
The other Hadith says
Right, what do we understand? We
understand that whichever genetic
material is stronger and more dominant,
the child will look like that one. What
was the problem with that? In fact,
It's true that it's whichever genetic
material which WHICHEVER GENETIC
MATERIAL
IT DOESN'T SAY anything about discharge.
Come to Islam. You don't say anything
about this.
COME TO ISLAM.
COME TO ISLAM. UH NO, NO, thank you.
Yeah, whatever, whatever, get lost. All
right, we're going to end the live
stream there. You don't waste time with
these creatures. La la la la.
>> What are these people saying? I think
the guy might come back to Islam.
>> Bro, he's whatever, man.
>> The guy after all of this
he went from not believing God to
believing now he What do you know? He
No, that No, he went to a good place, I
think. It's good I heard you speak
Arabic today. It's good. That was the
best thing about it. That was about it.
All right, brothers and sisters, we're
going to end the live stream here. Any
last words? No.
Mercy to humanity. Support the work. We
are close to 11,000 pounds now. We are
going to be helping the Muslims and the
Christians and whoever's out there who's
oppressed. And that was something that
we have achieved tonight. And this was
whatever. This guy, man, flipping it.
Did my head in.
>> [laughter]